[Musique]
et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papy
grenier papi PAP papoucou PAP les
enfants vous vous avez pas vu c'est
peut-être ma
cataracte tu nous racontes une histoire
oh une histoire est-ce que je vous ai
raconté la fois où j'étais mineur dans
l' mais si regardez on va s'éclater il y
a du tamium il y a du zyc il a de
l'aluminium il y a de l'or pap ça va
alors plutôt est-ce que je vous ai
raconté la fois où j'ai affronté des
poney sauvages dans les terres désolées
du Nord
Balos il arrive qui ça aldwin le roi des
dragons
non sur PC quoi non c'était en 2011 et à
cette époque Nintendo ne fabriquait pas
encore des lanmissiles sol he pour
abattre les avions de
ligne ça nous a tous surpris tout a
commencé alors que je m'étais fait
arrêter que je me rendais dans une
charrette pour me faire exécuter le dit
normal en quelque sorte il m'avait fait
descendre et puis là il y a un mec qui
m'avait demandé et vous qui êtes-vous
bon alors oui j'ai mis un peu de temps à
répondre parce qu'après un stylon trajet
c'était difficile de se remettre des
idées en place et pourtant je sais pas
le type là il avait l'air choqué petite
nature de nos jours je te jure oh enfin
bref je savais qui j'étais j'étais le
dovakin l'enfant de dragon il fait
froid monsur on a été attaqué par aldwin
j'ai donc fui pour me diriger vers
blanche rive la ville la plus proche
pour avertir qu'un dragon a attaqué j'ai
réussi à m'en débarrasser au prix d'un
combat terrible c'est vrai ça bah ok en
fait je me suis planqué j'ai laissé les
autres faire voilà mais j'ai quand même
moi qui aspiré l' du dragon et voilà
comment j'ai sauvé la ville et tous ses
habitants papi tu as dû être un héros
oui mais quand on a fêté ma victoire bah
je voulais bouffer une pomme mais je
l'ai raté j'ai pris l'assiette et du
coup ils m'ont foutu en tôle ti [ __ ]
d'un grat
pour me remercier d'avoir vaincu le
dragon le yarle de la ville m'a fait
accompagner de Lidia ma compagnon
j'étais son tan nous allons affronter
les
dragons tiens c'est bizarre c'était pas
comme ça dans mes
[Musique]
souvenirs voilà c'est mieux
ça avec texture 4 pour les tétons je te
F le lien avec ldia à mes côté dans le
groupe je me suis dit qu'il était je
dire qu'il était temps d'aller rendre
visite au grisb en montagne pour en
apprendre plus sur mes pouvoirs nous
allons partir pour un long voyage ce
sera un périple dangereux mais tu es mon
compagnon et je prendrai soin de toi
d'accord je ferai tout pour vous montane
allez
grouille les grisbb habita tout en haut
de la plus haute des montagnes de bord
de ciel ça allait être un long voyage on
y arrivera jamais la côte est bien trop
pentue
sur le chemin d'ailleurs j'en profitais
pour ramasser tout un tas de plantes
l'alchimie Ctait quelque chose de très
important en ce tempsl pour ça on
ramassait des plantes on mélangeit au
hasard et on voyait ce que ça
faisait ça fera un très bon
poison d'ailleurs il fallait tout
ramasser pas que les plantes la moindre
chose pouvait être utile parce que
certains trucs te donnent des
résistances magiques quand tu les manger
cétait bien pratique un peu bizarre
aussi attention l CEM utilise des sort
de froid mange cet orteil de
géant
allez après au pire si tu avais plus de
potion il y avait d'autres solution
Lydia je crois que c'est fini pour moi
non montane
tenez vous voulez un papillon avec votre
chou évidemment je te parle même pas des
armes et des armures qu'on ramassé pour
toujours améliorer notre équipement
alors Lydia tu te sens mieux protégé non
tu as raison il te manque un casque
tiens maiss ça en arrivant chez le
grisbb il m'avait appris que j'étais un
genre délu de la prophétie il m'avait
aussi appris un mot en dragon et ça me
donnait la capacité d'éternuer super
fort non et tout de suite je suis allé
m'entraîner sur des
monstres je ferai tout pour vous mon tan
oh là là je lui en ai mis des
tanéin tuas compris je t San je desan
PAP Mony viage a commencé après ma
sortie de chez les grisbarbes bord des
ciel était un monde vaste un plein de
races différentes les Pier des bandits
c'était les CIT cette rase d'homchat
heureusement je savais comment les gérer
grâce à ma magie donnez-moi votre argent
si vous voulez
[Musique]
vivre mais quelle est cette
sorcellerie j'ai visité les moindres
recoins de bord deciiel mes journées
c'était surtout genreb j'allais dans les
tombeaux et je volais des trucs dans les
tombes je fouillis les urs de funérair
pour voir s'il y avait pas de l'argent
aussi et puis jouer avec le crâne des
morts B après il fallait faire attention
il fallait pas prendre trop de trucs
quand même ah quelle jolie
fleur et au fil de mes aventures je me
suis même marié oh l'amour ah c'était
plus simple avant il fallait juste
porter un collier de Mara et parler à
une femme et hop pas besoin de
restaurant de sortir et toutes ces
conneries là elle acceptit direct pour
la vie en plus et ça marchait avec
n'importe qui alors pour moi le choix
était évident
Lydia après tout ce qu'on a traversé
j'ai quelque chose d'important à vous
demander oui est-ce que vous voulez bien
vous pousser pousse ma femme papi quoi
entretemps entreur d'ailleurs j'ai
profité de mes voyages pour intégrer
plein de guildes différentes le monde en
était rempli il y avait la guilde des
voleurs la Guil des bardes des mages des
guerriers des assassins j'étais dans
toutes les guildes en même temps était
sympa quand même plus le temps passa
plus tout ça devenait une routine les
tombeaux à pillé les dragons à exterminé
j'étais devenu de plus en plus fort
j'avais les meilleures armes les
meilleures armures et je maîtrisais
toutes les magies oh là là tout le monde
avait confiance en moi regardez c'est
l'enfant de dragon notre hér à
tous et je me demande bien pourquoi
d'ailleurs mais papi tu l'as revu le roi
des dragons du début oh non c'est aldown
le dragon légendaire on l'appelle le
Dévoreur des mondes le fléo des temps et
des rois ancien nombre libéré ou le dieu
nordique de la
[Musique]
destruction paracatoche merci novakin
vous avez sauvé bord de ciel célèbrons
ça avec un verre allez mais Trinon à la
mort d'aldwin à la
vôre
oh ben finalement ça s'est plutôt bien
passé papi c'est pas une histoire ça
c'est un jeu vidéo qui non c'est pas
vrai je me souviens parfaitement de
l'ydia et sa super tenue sexy que je
avais acheté même qu'on voyé C petit
merde papi papi tu nous racontes une
autre histoire ah bien sûr mais ça sera
pour la prochaine
[Musique]
fois